vielen dank für die einladung zur
gesamten workshop ich freue mich sehr
dass ich hier fast vortragen darf es ist
ein workshop insofern ist auch mein
vortrag als work in progress zu
verstehen ich will da gar nichts
definitiv ist jetzt unbedingt
beanspruchen sondern einfach mal ein
paar thesen philosophische thesen zur
diskussion stellen und bin gespannt auch
die diskussion gerne auch der vortrag
die aufgezeichnet und hinterher auf
youtube auf dem ag kanal freue ich mich
sehr genau das thema lautet und
theologie des computerspiels genauer
wird sich noch zeigen dass es eigentlich
auch um die ontologie des
computerspielens geht darauf werde ich
aber noch ein bisschen genauer eingehen
und sage ich ein bisschen was zur
gliederung meines vortrags
zunächst werde ich etwas zum thema
computerspiele und computerspielen im
verhältnis zur lebenswelt sagen wir
haben ja auch in der ag digitalität
forschung eine unterarbeitsgruppe
digitalität und lebenswelt und maria
sehr viel mitwirkt
darauf richtet sich jetzt auch der
vortrag dann werde ich was sagen über
computerspiele als spiele das heißt ich
werde jetzt im folgenden ein paar
versuche unternehmen computerspiele zu
bestimmen was sind sie eigentlich einmal
als spiele er hofft es sprachspiel ein
auf wittgenstein
computerspielen antrieb kandidat als
medien als neue medien ist eine
möglichkeit computerspiele auch
philosophisch zu bestimmen darum geht es
mir auch so ein bisschen den vortrag
dann ein weiterer kandidat
computerspiele als fiktionen die alle
kennen diese aktivistische
interpretation von computerspielen
computerspiele als simulationen und zum
schluss computerspiele als virtuelle
realität und das betrifft auch das thema
dieses workshops und ausschließt
abschließend möchte ich etwas sagen zur
praxis des computerspielens mit blick
auf und logische frage stellung
ich beginne mal ganz allgemein mit einer
charakterisierung von computerspielen
von einem phänomen das auch in das
größere phänomene digitalisierung oder
genauer gesagt lebensweltlichen
digitalität gehört also computerspiele
sehen ich glaube das kann man wirklich
so sagen ja auch andere phänomene der
digitalisierung terrasse phänomene sie
breiten sich aus sie durchdringen
verschiedene lebensbereiche
sie halten einzug sie finden einzugehen
ganz verschiedenen bereichen zur
lebenswelt arbeit die ich würde gerne
fiction bildung wissenschaft kultur
sport dass ballack sich jetzt sport kann
man ja auch als kulturveranstaltung
ansehen als es sind ganz viele bereiche
wo computer spielen eine rolle spielen
und das zeichnet sie in meinen augen
auch philosophisch aus sie werden auch
nicht mehr nur als zeitvertreib
angesehen und nutzlose spielerei das
gibt es natürlich auch spielereien ein
computer spielen aber ich glaube es wird
diesen wesen wenn man überhaupt vom
wesen sprechen wichtig des
computerspiels nicht gerecht eine bloße
spielerei sind sie werden immer mehr das
haben jetzt auch hier gesehen heute und
werden es noch sehen als philosophischen
interessante phänomene und auch ernst
genommen
wir müssen allerdings und darauf kommt
es mit diesem vortrag jetzt an zwischen
computerspielen als medialen und
ästhetischen phänomen der
digitalisierung und der praxis des
computerspielens unterscheiden das ist
für mich eine ganz wichtige referenz an
dass man auch wieder geschaut was tun
wir eigentlich auch unter logisch
gesehen wenn wir computerspiele
ich möchte zum beleg meiner thesen die
aber sicherlich auch viele erstmal
teilen werden aus dem die leiterin der
usk der unterhaltungssoftware
selbstkontrolle das zitieren aus diesem
leid kriterien für die
jugendschutzrechtlich bewertung von
computer und videospielen aus dem jahr
2020 habe hier ein ausrufezeichen hinter
unterhaltungs software gemacht weil ich
so ein bisschen in frage stellen möchte
ob computerspiele angemessen als
unterhaltungssoftware charakterisiert
sind also es kann sein und dafür
argumentiert dass unsere bisherigen
kategorien mit denen computer spiele
versucht wurden zu verstehen sie
begreifen dass die irgendwie nicht mehr
ausreichen um diesen aktuellen
wandlungen gerecht zu werden die wir
aber auch schon einige seit einigen
jahren beobachten was das computerspiel
angenommen und diesem jahr 2020 das
zitieren und zwar folgendes zitat
computerspiele sind ein
selbstverständlicher teil unserer
alltagskultur und finden auch unter
künstlerischen aspekten beachtung
technisch machbares und ästhetischer
auszug können sich eine art und weise
verbinden das spiele merkmal einer kunst
folgen der zeitgenössischen unterhaltung
durch die chancen der interaktivität
können sich entwickler wie spieler durch
das medium ausdrücken sich kritisch mit
gesellschaft in ihren prozessen
auseinandersetzen und jetzt kommt und
dabei wirklichkeit entwicklung und
veränderung reflektieren die wichtigen
punkte für mich habe ich jetzt mal fett
markiert hier wird natürlich immer noch
dass computerspiele als ein medium
angesehen und das möchte ich auch ein
bisschen frage stellen also wirklich
adäquat als medien bestimmt jetzt kommt
hier aber gleich noch auf seite 4 in
diesem
diesen kriterien noch eine weitere
country sieren sie tat im vergleich zu
anderen medien wird immer mehr zeiten
das erlebnisangebot digitales spielen
auf dem pc konsolen oder mobilen
plattform investiert dabei sind
spielerin inzwischen die allen
gesellschaftlichen bereichen und
altersgruppen zu finden wieder pervasive
dimension ist bezieht sich nicht nur auf
bestimmte jugendliche
altersgruppen
erwähnt wird nämlich noch das darüber
hinaus auch die elterngeneration jahr
2020 zunehmend selbst erfahrung mit
computerspielen erworben hat es also
nicht mehr so dass computerspiele immer
nur die sache der kinder ist der jugend
sondern auch die eltern haben
mittlerweile einen hintergrund eine
erfahrung in der praxis des
computerspiels oder spielen und das ist
sehr wichtig für die lebensweltliche
verbreitung dieses phänomens jetzt
möchte ich so ein bisschen was sagen zu
dem spiel begriff weil wittenstein sätze
recht darauf hingewiesen hat dass der
spieler begriffen der tour gespielt und
unscharf ist er sagt seinen
philosophischen untersuchungen ist
bestehe nur familien ähnlichkeiten
zwischen diesen verschiedenen spielen
trainieren zitat er sagt betrachtet zb
einmal die vorgänge die ihr spielen nein
ich meine brettspiele kartenspiele
ballspiele kampfspiele usw was ist allen
diesen gemeinsam sagt nicht es muss den
etwas gemeinsam science und sie sind sie
nicht spielen und dann schauen ob in
allen etwas gemeinsam ist dann kommt er
zu dem schluss und so können wir durch
die vielen vielen anderen gruppen von
spielen gehen ähnlichkeiten auftauchen
und verschwinden sehen und das ergebnis
dieser betrachtung lautet nun wir sehen
ein kompliziertes netz von ähnlichkeiten
die einander übergreifen und kreuzen
ähnlichkeiten im großen und im kleinen
aus dem philosophischen untersuchungen
wie verhält sich jetzt mit dem spiel
dass die computerspiele auszeichnet hier
muss man jetzt erstmal fragen inwieweit
sind computerspiele überhaupt für das wo
fisch korrekt als spiele charakterisiert
und hier möchte ich friedrich schiller
zitieren britische land anführen der wie
ich finde es jetzt recht darauf
aufmerksam gemacht dass ich im spiel
ganz allgemeinen jeder form des spiels
in mir scheint die freiheit des menschen
exemplarisch manifestieren also freiheit
und genauer gesagt autonomie selbst
gesetzgebung selbstbestimmung die hängen
ganz enges spiel zusammen ein spiel
spielt der mensch mit wirklichkeit und
möglichkeit zu meiner interpretation
verschönern
mensch ist im spiel einerseits an regeln
und die wirklichkeit gebunden könnte
dass die reality constraints nennen also
es gibt da ganz klar wer dinge die nicht
verhandelbar sind doch gibt er sich
diese regeln mitunter autonomen selbst
indem er zb realitäten simulieren
fingieren oder gar virtualisieren kann
durch das spiel und dieses zitat kennen
sie bestimmt alle das spiel ist nach
schiller nächstes jahr eine
reglementieren der einschränkung sondern
vielmehr eine erweiterung des menschen
das zitat eine erweiterung das finde ich
sehr sehr treffen diese anthropologische
bestimmung und dann kommt dieses zitat
der mensch gilt nur wollen voller
bedeutung des fundes mensch ist und er
ist nur da ganz mensch wo er spielt also
spielen wieder hier als etwas uhr
anthropologisches vielleicht sogar noch
mehr als eine metaphysische tätigkeit
der eben die freiheit des menschen
besonders zur geltung kommt und ich
stimme ihre schüler vollkommen zu und
glaube dass man das vor allem auch auf
das phänomen des computerspiels beziehen
kann diese metaphysische tätigkeit des
spiels worin besteht jetzt die
besonderheit von computerspielen etwa im
gegensatz zu brettspielen wie schach mir
scheint der unterschied darin bestehen
dass die freiheit des computerspiels die
freiheit des schachspiels performativ
übersteigt was meine ich jetzt in
computerspielen manifestieren wie ein
anderen regel und wirklichkeit bezug als
wir sind red spielen tun und die form
des spielens ist qualitativ durch ihre
reibungslose zeit das ist wieder luciano
florida wieder von sprach und die
vernetzung im digitalen raum aus
gezeigte digitalen raum man kann doch
genau darüber diskutieren wir hatten ja
auch im vortrag den raum was darunter zu
verstehen ist der erscheint mir ganz
wichtig zu sein und computerspiele auch
unter logisch zu charakterisieren
deswegen scheint mir computerspiele auch
im passen mehr zu sein als nur spiel
nachdem was man jetzt eben unter spielen
versteht meine these ist wir können
computerspiele durch ihre spezifische
form und praxis ist wirklichkeit bezugs
von anderen spielen wie zum beispiel
spielen unterscheiden glaube dass hier
ein anderer wirklichkeit bezug zu finden
es in computerspielen jetzt richtig
computerspiele mal als neues medium
untersuchen ich klappe jetzt ein paar
versuche ab computerspiele zu bestimmen
sie wissen alle das wort medium computer
und kann so viel bedeutet wie
vermittlungsinstanz jetzt können wir uns
fragen wie vielen vermitteln
computerspiele etwas und falls ja
zwischen wem wir hatten gesehen in der
charakterisierung der usk die hat
computerspiele als unterhaltungsstoff
als konsum medium karte sieht und ich
finde dass das zu kurz ich glaube dass
computerspiele von anderen neuen medien
muss man eingestellt lassen wie filmen
zeitungen büchern verschieden sind da
sie nicht nur passiv konsumiert sondern
auch performativ vollzogen werden also
da findet mehr stört als nur die
rezession dann findet eine praxis statt
die ist ganz interessant die muss man
genauer beschreiben das ist so ein punkt
von mir computerspielen bedeutet das
haben wir schon ein bisschen bei
schiller gesehen das herstellen eines
komplexen wirklichkeit verhältnisses und
die mediale seite die vermittelnde seite
tritt dahinter immer mehr zurück oft
scheint es zwar so als ob die praxis des
computerspielens blusen konsum besteht
stichwort unterhaltungsmedium allerdings
finde ich dass die reduzierte
körperlichkeit die wm am computer
spielen durchaus vorfinden es gibt immer
wieder auch computerspielen die
versuchen den körper wieder ein zu
beziehen dass das nicht zum schluss
verleiten darf das in computerspielen
keine aktivität enteilt das ist in
meinen augen eine realistische
reduktionistischen sicht des
computerspiels haben dass man hier sich
nur berieseln lässt und nichts tut ich
glaube man tut eben sehr viel und sehr
interessant dies verweist bereits auf
eine besonderheit des computerspiels
ziel seiner speziellen handlungs theorie
und darin auch in seiner und logie
bestehen es gehe ich auf den nächsten
kandidaten computerspiele als fiktionen
in computerspielen werden die erstens
mit fiktiven gehalten konfrontiert also
mit einer rahmen ab geschichte einer
rahmenhandlung narrativ übernehmen darin
aber auch fiktiv rollen die können
vorgegeben sein die können wir uns aber
vielleicht auch selbst wenn wir zum
beispiel an computerspiele dingen wo wir
unsere charaktere zu einem sehr hohen
grad individualisieren können durch
avatar und wir fungieren auch in diesen
fiktiven rahmen handlungen eigene
handlung also fiktion findet in
computerspielen da kann in
computerspielen muss man aber sagen auf
ganz verschiedenen ebenen stattfinden
wir bekommen also häufig in
computerspielen eine geschichte erzählt
ihr schreiben aber auch die geschichte
individuell fort das ist ganz wichtig
ist es wieder nicht nur dieses passive
erleben oder leidenschaft das aktive vor
spinnen von innovativen fiktiven
gehalten wir machen uns gewissermaßen in
computerspielen die fiktion zu einer
etwas vorgegebenes der hat den rahmen
machen wir uns zeigen und wir bestimmen
uns dabei auch autonomen interaktiv
selbst wie eben die geschichte aus und
weiter geht es gibt bestimmte bereiche
die sind determiniert aber es gibt auch
wiederum viele bereiche in spielen die
unsere freiheit letztendlich überlassen
sind wir sind also meine these selbst
ihre teile des computerspiels und darin
finde ich unterscheiden sich
computerspiele von film und roman
wo wir sicherlich auch die wird die
bilder die wir im geistigen auge
erzeugen zum gewissen grade selbst zu
verantworten haben ich gehe da hat
dieselben geistigen eindrücke oder
bilder bei demselben roman und beim film
ist es noch extremer da kriegen wir doch
größtenteils der selbe bild präsentiert
natürlich verarbeiten wie es immer
wieder auf den verschiedenen reise
gekommen andere assoziationen aber
worauf es mir ankommt ist die aktivität
ist in computerspielen viel größer als
bei medien die filmen oder mann und
deswegen finde ich dass computerspieler
nicht adäquat durch den begriff der
immersion des eintauchens bestimmt sind
das kann er wie mir scheint an und fiel
um der fall sein denn die version ist
immer mit medialer hetero- nomi
kompatibel in der immersion können wir
ganz fremd stückzahlen solange wir uns
ganz darauf einlassen wir sind aber
nicht frei diesen dieser hinsicht wie
wir sind computerspielen sind deswegen
halte ich den begriff der immersion
nicht besonders hilfreich für die
philosophische bestimmung von
computerspielen jetzt kommen wir auf den
weiteren punkt computerspiele als
simulationen in computerspielen geht es
nicht nur um sie zion
darauf bin ich gerade zu sprechen wie
kommst du eben auch um simulationen das
heißt um nachahmungen oder nachbildungen
einer wirklichkeit beispiel dafür sind
zum beispiel flugsimulatoren oder kampf
simulatoren denkmal zum beispiel an den
microsoft leider den 9 wirklich
beeindruckend
realistisch ist aber doch nicht ganz
realistisch das heißt wir finden auch in
komplexen simulationen immer fiktionale
gehalte die einfach nicht mehr der
realität entsprechen aus verschiedenen
gründen
zeitgründe wir können den flug prozess
beschleunigen künstlich kann ein
zeitraffer einbeziehen wir können dinge
mit dem flugzeug tun auch im
fleischkleid simulierte die wir mit
einem wirklichen flugzeug aus und von
physikalischen gegebenheiten einfach
nicht tun können also wir sehen selbst
sogenannte
simulatoren haben fiktionale elemente
wir selbst simulieren in computerspielen
jedoch nicht nur reale ist daneben auch
fiktive handlung umzieht und eine
simulation einer fiktiven handlung kann
etwa in form eines rollenspiels bestehen
wir simulieren zb die handlung einem
bier in der simulierten magier in und
simulieren eine andere simulierte person
in einem simulierten frosch zu verzocken
ich glaube man muss alle handlungen
unter dem gesichtspunkt der simulation
betrag der simulation von fiktionen
computerspiele existieren jedoch in der
spannung von simulationen fiktionen wir
wollen nicht nur simulieren so wir
wollen darin auch mit der wirklichkeit
auf eine fiktive weise spielen ja sogar
auch neue wirklichkeit erzeugt glaube
dass das der bereits des computerspiels
ausmacht diese möglichkeit wirklich neue
wirklichkeit nicht kommen doch am ende
drauf virtuelle realitäten selbst zu
erzeugen und nicht nur zu simulieren
oder zu fingieren beanspruchen also
indem wir computer mehr zu tun als nur
zu konsumieren
simulieren oder zu fingieren und
beanspruchte einen autonomen
wirklichkeit zu und das zeichnet wenn
man es so macht in meinen augen
computerspiele wirklich philosophisch
aus und jetzt komme ich zu dieser
weiteren bestimmung auf die ich schon
eingegangen bin nämlich computerspiele
als virtuelle realitäten das ist für
mich sozusagen der letzte punkt der
konsequenteste punkt der bestimmung von
computerspielen wir simulieren nicht nur
ein computer spielen hatte ich gesagt
sein jeder zeugen auch neue realität
virtuelle realitäten beispiele sind etwa
online multiplayer spiele wie world of
warcraft oder reisen worlds im meter
versus vormals im facebook mit das sind
jetzt nicht mehr nur simulationen sollen
das sind wirklich virtuelle kulturen man
kann auch schon wirklich sagen existenz
formen die nicht mehr angemessen durch
die begriffe simulation fiktion illusion
charakterisiert sind wir tun da wirklich
etwas wir haben es mit virtuellen
währungen zu tun die wirklich einen wert
haben und nicht nur ein simulierten wer
das heißt die handlungen vollziehen im
metaversum online multiplayer spielen
die sind mehr als bloße nationen
onlinespiele kulturen sind virtuelle
realitäten eigenen rechts der gelten
gewisse regeln und die regel sind mehr
als nur irgendwelche spielerische
konventionen und die entwicklung des
metaversum es geht noch stärken diese
richtung passiert wirklich neue
realitäten und verbindlichkeiten erzeugt
werden das heißt zu meine these
virtuelle realitäten denn wir
computerspiele an diesem gesichtspunkt
betraf betrachten wollen die entwickeln
sich sukzessive aus bloßen spielen
simulationen und fiktionen und zwar dann
wenn die regeln des spiels möglichst
inter subjektiv geteilt und im digitalen
raums zur segel vernetzt und auch
reibungslos institutionalisiert werden
wenn also die regeln wirklich
verbindlichkeit erlangen spielregeln und
das spiel dahinter immer mehr in den
hintergrund rückt jetzt möchte ich
abschließend versuchen die praxis des
computerspielens noch mal stärker ins
zentrum zu rücken und einem unter
logischen gesichtstuch da sich
computerspiele wie ich versucht habe
zeigen als komplexe formen und praktiken
von wirklichkeit bezug verstehen das
können wir sie insofern als eine form
und praxis von philosophie verstehen als
in ihnen die frage nach der realität
spielerisch verhandeln diesem freien
sinne die wendung ontologie des
computerspiels kann deshalb im sinne
eines genetisch subjektive und objektive
verstanden werden damit man nicht
folgendes die praxis des computerspiel
ist im grunde ist selbst eine form von
anthologien nämlich eine praxis der
perma format even wirklichkeit
verhandlung also der reflexion auf das
was eigentlich existiert hat ist konto
logi ebenso zeigt eine ethik des
computerspiels das computerspielen
selbst als eine form von ethik
verstanden werden kann inwiefern
noten im computerspielen auch die
moralischen grenzen von wirklichkeit
illusionen simulation und fick zwang
haus in dem wir sie spielerisch
verhandlung auch in bewegung bringen und
eine reflexion auf moralische grenzen
das nicht sie eben gerade die ethik ist
die reflexion auf die urahnen das können
wir auch in computerspielen tun das
heißt in letzter konsequenz das ist
meine starke these mit der ich auch den
vortrag enden lassen durch den letzter
konsequenz können wir verlosen
philosophisch computerspielen als
philosophische praxis verstehen
realistisch vielleicht aber so meine
these computerspielen kann durchaus auch
bedeutend zu philosophieren vielen dank
für die aufmerksamkeit